on se dit pas que c'est sorti de tout là
quand même regarde mais sors de l'eau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai toujours senti que j'avais un
problème d'alcool c'est à dire que quand
je buvais pas de la semaine c'est parce
que je me retenais de boire j'avais
vraiment envie de boire tout le temps
tout le temps tout le temps et puis à
partir du moment où j'ai accepté de
l'alcool tous les soirs les angoisses
sont devenus de plus en plus importantes
et à un moment donné un jour vous vous
levez un matin et vous êtes incapable de
fonctionner c'est-à-dire vous êtes
tellement pris d'angoisse vous êtes
tellement mal que vous êtes incapable de
fonctionner donc j'ai commencé à boire
un petit peu de whisky dans mon café ça
a commencé comme ça et puis de fil en
aiguille je suis arrivé à boire toute la
journée du matin au soir arrive c'est
pas là il en parle souvent et il a il
s'est souvent exprimé aussi sur le fait
qu'il a eu des pensées très obscures il
a suicide très sérieuse donc ça aussi il
faut le dire parce qu'en général c'est à
ça que ça mène et alcoolisme mondain non
mais l'alcoolisme dur comme le sien oui
comprenez-vous que les stars montrent
tout regardez bien ce qui s'est passé il
y a eu enjoyPhoenix à montrer qu'elle
avait de l'acné il y a kim Kardashian
qui psoriasis il y a sur les gens mais
surtout ça non il y a un moment Mathieu
moi je dis toujours la même chose mais
par exemple mon père Françoise Hardy il
en rêvait elle était belle elle avait 20
ans quand elle va chez Ruquier qu'elle
s'assie et qu'elle dit bah voilà j'ai
des pertes vaginales j'ai mal là j'ai un
sein qui tombe génial non ça c'est rêver
des mecs
il faut faire la distinction entre ceux
qui font ça sincèrement et ceux qui font
ça par effet de mode parce que quand kim
Kardashian et Nabilla montre leur acné
alors qu'elle passe leur temps à montrer
des photos retouchées à se refaire tout
le corps des corps qui ne sont même pas
naturels et nous font croire que c'est
naturel d'avoir trois boutons ça c'est
du buzz c'est surfer sur un élève
84% des Français dans le milieu des
stars sont pistonnés alors j'ai d'autres
chiffres la politique c'est 35% la
littérature 11% notamment envie d'être
avec la musique 10% et pour 70% des
Français le piston reste aujourd'hui la
plus grande forme d'injustice je dis que
c'est normal de pistonner son enfant
s'il a du talent par exemple
si je peux l'aider je pense que toutes
les mamans dans le public elles peuvent
aider leurs enfants avoir un job elle le
feront et tous les papas
si l'enfant est nul c'est préjudice
c'est ce qu'elle dit d'ailleurs c'est ce
qu'elle dit Alexandra Lamy elle dit si
elle avait été nulle la pauvre la mette
à l'écran c'est pas lui rendre service
quand on a vu par exemple Lou Doillon tu
parlais franchement
quand elle a fait actrice elle était nul
à chier après elle a trouvé sa voile
elle est devenue chanteuse et elle était
exceptionnelle il y a des enfants qui
vont toujours ramer qui vont toujours
être
tu as annoncé il y a pas longtemps c'est
vrai qu'en revanche financièrement c'est
plus compliqué tu vis du RSA c'est vrai
ça bien sûr c'est quoi le reste ça c'est
400 euros par mois 530 euros par mois ou
tu vis en fait tu partages un peu ta ta
maison entre entre ta maman et
Eric prayer ton meilleur ami dans le sud
de la France c'est ça j'ai beaucoup chez
ma maman oui donc tu es un peu
itinéraire
personne ne me croit même ma famille mes
amis ne m'ont pas cru ma maman comme on
vit beaucoup ensemble et qu'on est
beaucoup plus proche le remarque
maintenant il est vrai que dès qu'il y a
des souple licence sur mon compte ils
sont souvent soufflés
[Musique]
plus pour faire bannir non j'aime pas
parler d'argent parce que
il est où cet argent
j'ai pas de voiture j'ai pas de maison
j'ai pas d'appart j'ai pas de c'est
bizarre quand même avec tout cet argent
tout est parti tout est parti et ben de
la banque donc déjà on fait du bien
carte bancaires j'ai changé quatre fois
de banque
ou ta maman je veux pas dire j'accuse
personne
je suis je suis justement donc j'ai pas
utilisé mon agent ci bien sûr parce que
ça fait quand même assez longtemps que
je les vends je sais que vous êtes
réconcés avec ta maman mais si par
hasard
tu découvrais que cette enquête que
l'argent qui a été tiré c'était souvent
ta maman tu lui en voudrais beaucoup
mais comment tu pourrais
quand
dire mais c'est qui
des pâtes donc franchement elle m'aurait
volé cet argent
même pas il y a des malfrats où j'en
sais rien ma mère l'a vu une fois j'ai
travaillé j'ai eu l'euro sur mon compte
cinq jours plus tard il reste 70 il y a
eu un moment difficile dans ta vie tu en
as parlé c'était tenté de suicide dieu
merci et non pas été réussi
ce genre de choses là ou pas rien on
peut te dire voilà ça fait 10 ans j'ai
arrêté la drogue l'alcool
que j'entends ce soir et bah c'est très
bien
machin comme ça une photo on dit elle
est défoncer je vais te dire pourquoi
parce que regarde quand on regarde ton
Instagram on a vu un pas longtemps on se
dit il y a est-ce qu'on peut en voir un
Instagram ou tu annonçais que tu pouvais
faire des vidéos et tout ça si on peut
le voir s'il vous plaît voilà Lolo on se
dit pas que c'est une fille qui est
sorti de tout là quand même regarde mais
sors de l'eau Lolo s'il te plaît pas
à moi
faire des conneries tu fais des
conneries écoute
ça allait comme ça ben je fais bah voilà
me dis pas que tu es dans un état là tu
es pas nickel c'est le discours il est
9h du matin mais c'est pas le problème
[Rires]
de love story ils sont assez désagréable
quand il parle de vous il vous dénigre
pas mal je trouve et voilà ils vous ont
lâché totalement et ils disent limite
pour certains non mais nous on veut pas
ça y est on a tout enfin limite c'est
honteux pour eux j'ai enfin moi je le
ressens comme ça ça vous fait quoi de
voir ce cet humiliant quand même vous
voyez ce que je veux dire c'est que ça
fait mal au cœur humiliant non j'en ai
rien à faire ça me touche à l'intérieur
j'aimerais qu'on te montre une photo
quand tu revois cette photo là qu'est-ce
que tu as envie de dire à cette jeune
fille a dit à 20 ans à peu près Loana
aujourd'hui fais plus attention et ben
c'est ce que je te dis aussi